joining me now Lee zeldon former New
York congressman and gubernatorial
candidate Jason Chaffetz also former
house oversight chair Fox News
contributor as well as Mike Davis
article 3 project founder and president
Lee
um you're a Jewish American is it
anti-semitic now to criticize George
soros's involvement in DA's offices and
elections no not at all and if you know
Ron DeSantis as Jason and I served with
him in the House of Representatives he
is someone who has a lot of fantastic
relationships with the Jewish Community
ties that have only strengthened and
something that has been a high priority
for him as governor of Florida on the
merits George Soros is funding district
attorney candidates across the country
including in New York City with Alvin
Bragg who are looking at D.A as a term
that should stand for defense attorney
not district attorney Alvin Bragg on his
day one memo said that he wasn't going
to enforce all sorts of crimes across
the board and other offenses he was
going to treat as lesser included
offenses we see it with cashless Bell
and eroded support of law enforcement
it's the agenda it's the defund the
police agenda and all the different
prongs of it that George Soros is behind
with these D.A races across the country
including this year that's what people
are attacking on the merits nothing to
do with his religion now Jason Bragg's
office responded to House Republicans in
a letter today writing that you and many
of your colleagues have chosen to
collaborate with Mr Trump's efforts to
vilify and denigrate the Integrity of
elected State prosecutors and trial
judges we urge you to let the criminal
justice process proceed without unlawful
political interference now Jason uh as
former oversight chair your reaction to
this I guess you never can say anything
about an ongoing judicial process no no
comment whatsoever
yeah it all hands off and of course that
works both ways right Laura it always
works that way with the Democrats you
know now come on look I was the chairman
of the oversight committee the oversight
committee was founded in 1814. you can
investigate anything at any time you can
do it to inform legislation look at
where Federal money is being spent and
you can certainly do it when you believe
there might be an election interference
so what Congressman Jim Jordan the
chairman of Judiciary is doing and and
comer and not the others is exactly
legitimate there is no reason why why
they can't do this and all these excuses
the Democrats will come up with there's
an ongoing investigation oh there's a
prosecution or there's all these things
that didn't slow him down on January 6
did it it didn't slow anybody down after
9 11 and it should not slow them down in
this case he should come to Congress he
should have to testify and there should
be a paperwork Trail between his office
the White House and any democratic
operatives that is fair game for
Congress and the American people deserve
to know it and I have to ask the
question of Mike here about the makeup
of this office in the New York DA's
group what do we need to know about them
as a whole because there's a big effort
to say oh well you're attacking these
these brave men and women or just public
servants you're you're viciously
attacking them so to that you say well I
think that you have to look at these
prosecutors in the Manhattan DA's office
for potential bias including I
understand that they hired someone from
the Biden justice department to come
help Soros funded Manhattan D.A Alvin
Bragg run this thing if you go look at
Alvin Bragg's Twitter accounts his
personal Twitter account and his
Manhattan D.A office Twitter account
they they're showing his obvious bias
that they're out to get Trump he ran
campaign commercials on this and to say
congress can't look into this is just
silly Congress has a responsibility
under the 14th Amendment uh section 5 of
the 14th Amendment to make sure that we
have equal justice and due process in
the states of this country that is
clearly a legislative function also
federal funds go from the justice
department to the state of New York and
the Manhattan DA's office and they could
also look at it is there any collusion
between the Biden justice department and
the Manhattan Diego remember finally the
Manhattan D.A is using a federal
election law statute apparently as the
predicate to bring this uh bogus New
York felony indictment so this is all
within congress's oversight purview
again holding back the document itself
so we don't know quite what's in the
document that in and of itself raises a
lot of eyebrows but Lee um I noticed on
the cover of today's front page of
today's Wall Street Journal
it presented kind of a chilling
um image and and the one hand that the
story Trump indicted over hush money and
then the other story you see there on
the right
um talking about the U.S condemning
Russia's arrest of a Wall Street Journal
reporter of course we all condemn that
but is there any irony in thatly I mean
putting putting him you know trying to
put in jail your Chief political
opponent putting in jail uh a reporter
who's writing critical pieces about your
Administration anyone else notice that
oh yeah absolutely and in this case you
have the an entity and we're not talking
about the Federal Election Commission
taking action we're not talking about
the Department of Justice taking action
we're talking about a highly particle a
partisan uh district attorney in the
borough of New York County trying to
lock up a former president who's also
right now in the lead to get the
nomination of the Republican party as a
New Yorker and I've been interning for
over 19 years I'm not even nowhere I
can't think of any case where a County
district attorney in this state has ever
prosecuted a federal campaign finance
charge at all and Alvin Bragg said
before he even took it office that this
was going to be his highest priority he
was going to personally be supervising
it he didn't know what the charge was
going to be he didn't know what the
facts were but he said he was going to
make sure that this happened a whole
bunch of irony where you should see
President Biden the Biden Administration
the Democratic party speaking out
because last I would say is if the shoe
was on the other foot and if this was a
republican district attorney going after
a Democratic president they'd be losing
their minds over it
um and Jason do you think as I do that
Bragg is hoping he can ride this all the
way to the Governor's Mansion in New
York
oh yeah absolutely I think this is a
political tool I think it's actually
bait that he's putting out there hoping
that Republicans and so-called Mega
Republicans are going to go out there
and overreact and you know engage in
some sort of violence but no I think
this is purely political oh yeah panel
great to see you thank you hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else